they finally fix this [ __ ] garage
door - you know I've been here for what
two months now and every time I try to
open this thing I'm gonna do it manually
you see that the fact that the garage
door [ __ ] works watch you go can you
please look at our outfit right here
it's called a fig bar
growing up I used to love Fig Newtons I
know one Swedish bastard that hates Fig
Newtons which I don't [ __ ] understand
but these are a healthy alternative by
nature's bakery energy for life's great
journeys stone ground whole wheat good
for me
sponsor me make us bakery
[Music]
so today what would be like is we're
gonna shoot a sketch I haven't done a
sketch in a very long time and we're
shooting it with Laurence cow I wrote
this for Lawrence two years ago in a
different place and so we had to do a
lot of adjustments for this new sketch
today like for example there was a part
in this case we're all supposed to be on
rollerblades that you attach to your
shoes and all supposed to be pulled like
a leaf what the real conversation but
because we didn't have that we had to
make an adjustment and we had to add a
dolly cart instead the darling mandalas
my shoes but the sketch basically is
about how for me when I was younger
actually not even younger I say a few
years back I had this shoe obsession I
collected a crafting issues I sold most
of them now but it was to that point
where a lot of people who were quantico
sneaker heads they were these shoes but
they refused to wear them they refused
to put the [ __ ] feet in my shoes and
they don't want to crease them they
don't want to get the dirty it doesn't
make any sense because their [ __ ]
shoes are made to be warm so if you're
buying shoes out there just to have them
displayed in the case you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but yeah I was just kind of making fun
of myself so I'm pretty sure a lot of
you guys out there who used to be
sneaker heads what still like sneakers
so this day can relate to this so
hopefully I'll enjoy
ya got blue cheese and lemon yogurt it
smells so bad for a second I thought was
my feet come on feet stink sometimes but
it's the cheese thank god it's gross is
this possible that's all that's over
trying to find out yeah my yeah my hips
loose this looks so dangerous dude
let's try there we go
and it maybe you should go on the bench
- okay are you sure yeah
one nope now I am
my ball we cannot do that again my ass
is really into your life I'm gonna have
to do it [ __ ] no you have to lean
back can you hold my kill you hold me
can you hold me here huh you have to
hold me here oh gosh yep ready
[Music]
on to the LA River because we need to
find a puddle that's exactly what the LA
River is
but balsa thrush
why would you tell your mother dolly she
gave up quick I said equilibrium off
about your wrist snap tough
oh yes don't risk to do my email to my
calendar
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like a mistake you won't not prepared
you came out today look at the mirror
set you know what this is it this is the
chin again I want you to say what you
just said now say say tell me what your
deep thought was right then you make it
let you make it that's why you're doing
so often like you know what like I don't
understand because it's part this yes
you make it let you make